but it's lovely to see here it
collective earlier today we loved you in
Game of Thrones a Sir Roderick Cassell
what are your favorite memories and the
scenes of being in that show are just
from start to finish it was a really
good good fun shot we involved in I
started on the pilot before we went to
series and that was a great experience
because you know everybody's just a
single cast and you're looking to get
something very exciting off the ground
and so that was you know hard work but
very concentrated very sort of
collegiate filter so that was when we
found it had been successful it's just
an excellent excellent feel and then the
series itself was just lovely no no
really really good time doing it well
good actors you know good chums sir it
splendid now we've got so many memories
of your scenes remember when you were
resting Tyrion at the end as well that
was incredible
it was it was five I mean that was quite
early on because we shot out of order in
the four cities so we did I think four
or five and six we shot them early on in
fact my first my first three days were
the big ambush where there's a lot of
prior you know just after the arrest but
no the end the end of the Cross choice
was great stuff to do you know again
like so much of it you walk on at the
set and you just got look at this I mean
you know they're the decoration the food
you know all the other people that are
there dressed on the set it's from that
point of view from an actor's point of
view you know the detail and the
attention that's put into this the
settings is just magnificent I was I
watching some really wonderful sets like
the the Eyrie where the trial by combat
took place you know the moon door and
all that stuff just gigantic
wonderful things to be part of when
you're an actor and you walk ons or
something like that is it still kind of
a sense of or even if you've been
filming on it for a few days yeah I mean
it's really exciting I mean you know you
get used to it very quickly but walking
onto it for the first time you get a
real sense of scale and no sense of you
know the size of the thing that that
you're part of
with the unfortunate loss sir Roderick
far too soon didn't we and but what a
way to go wasn't it well even in the
show where people die on a fairly
regular basis it was it was a good death
I think you know besides splendid and
you know good good feedback for it and
for you know if you're gonna go and
nearly all of us in House Stark you end
up going one way or another yeah it's
quite nice to go out in style great
lines you had in those final moments as
well I mean what did you think when you
got that script oh we've got the script
I looked and I thought yes we can we can
do this this would be lovely and also
you know playing it with without and
with Donald and with the boys you know
and we'd all done so much work together
over the couple of years the kids
particularly have been a real a real joy
for all of us the work so it was lovely
I think the boys were genuinely upset on
the date it's very now it was sad for
them but and Christian as well it was a
distant work and emotional they very
intense but a good ending I think good
ending for a good character I don't know
how much he followed the show I mean
obviously your son Dan's in there as
Podrick Payne and brilliant character
great young actor though don't have you
seen what's been happening to see on
lately
good old Theon yes I mean he has he's
paid for this pair for he hasn't seen I
mean I think I think I'm one of the
people that thinks the unns probably had
enough you know there comes a point
where you know punishment and
retribution and you know I suppose karma
you know I think he's probably paid now
for what he's done he says he's a poor
lost soul and I don't see any redemption
for him sadly I can't
I can't see any way that he can dig
himself out the terrible hole that he's
dug himself in listen hard storylines
and watch isn't it but compelling and on
the last I mean talking about characters
and their various kind of fates along
the way I mean what kind of qualities do
you think you need to survive or even
thrive if you can in that very harsh
world of Game of Thrones I think that's
what George is writing about Princip
players and the other balance between
personal values and and public
responsibility and it's you know you
have on the one hand you have the stark
family who do have this you know very
solid very commendable sense of honor
but it hasn't profited them or the
people that they're supposed to be
looking after that's all I mean their
their sense of justice and their sense
of all that is so inflexible that they
all end up paying for it on the other
hand you don't want to be you know like
the lioness there's a little finger who
are you know you know just completely
immoral people with no sense of values
beyond doing what they can for
themselves at any given time so I think
what George is looking for is a balance
between the two and what your rights is
you know a great fable about how
difficult that is to to achieve that
balance you know to be a to be a good
person in a very very bad world that's
something one of the things that makes
his writing so you know so wonderful
just beyond the simple storytelling what
have you enjoyed most about watching
down on the screen and how do you feel
about how his character pods developed
well Isis been fantastic for us watch
though you know he said some very good
moments obviously you know Blackwater
was the first time that you really came
into prominence rather than just be in
this sort of the bubbling boy in the
background you know when he the
fascinating thing about pod is the
character is that the only time he seems
to be capable is you know either in a
bedroom surrounded by young women or on
the battlefield surrounded by big men
when he just focuses and does everything
that's required and then he just back in
himself again I enjoyed his his farewell
with Tyrion very much I mean I thought
the two of them were just just lovely
but the whole relationship there's a
triangular relationship between Italian
and pawed and brawn
it was lovely just these know these two
very much all they're more experienced
men in very different ways and and
there's a surrogate son and again
interestingly and what you're talking
about you know how do you try to be good
and in a bad world you had both those
men you know Teddy and the great
politician and brawn the great warrior
and you know both hardly sentimental man
but both of them in their very different
ways trying to be as good as possible to
do this rather sort of lost seemingly
incapable boy so that was that's all
been great to watch interesting to see
now down as well as pod with Brienne
isn't oh yeah that'll be very
interesting to see you know a very
different relationship developing there
but we'll see we'll see what happens
with pod but I think everybody knows now
that's a you know there's there's more
important than meets the eye
now of course I mentioned george RR
martin where you got the audition you're
reading avidly all the books on you i
wonder what you'd like to see happen
enlist next book that he's got to come
out winds of winter well I guess you
know if George sticks to his original
plan and we've got a cycle of of seven
books I suppose what what's going to be
happening in those that he'll be
focusing and he'll be hoarding things
down and and moving you know towards
whatever conclusion he's he's decided
upon you know like everybody else I've I
have no idea you know I've got my own
ideas like everyone what's going to
happen but I guess what you'll start to
do is you know
bring is very very wide and you know big
canvas into sharper detail now or guess
that's that's what's going to happen you
know we've got all these disparate story
lines on Westeros esos with the you know
whether the Greyjoy Kuan at Cena I think
when he obviously has to start coming to
whatever Eric way Mike sees he's going
to pay him for so I guess book six you
know we'll be moving in that direction
then then the the final book if that's
what it ends up being it will be just
you know all hands to the pumps see what
happens thanks I mean if you could have
any character on that throne at the end
of the day who would you like to see and
also if you could have been any other
character in the show who do you like to
swap with oh well I like Ben Roderick
very much my favorite character it's
like everybody someone says who's your
favorite game of Thrones character and
they go well my top five I suppose I
would like to bring Davos he's one of my
great favorites because he's similar
qualities to Roderick you know he's just
he's he's not a man of power but he's in
the service of man of power and he
always tries to do the best thing I
think that was is a very well
constructed good character who do I see
on the Iron Throne at the end hard to
say
I don't know Daenerys maybe I think she
would who knows what we did but I I
don't see any of the brutality and the
casual viciousness of the Targaryen lion
in her I see a much more developed and
human person and she might she might not
be a bad person to to have the reins of
power she certainly seems to do a good
job with you know the opportunities that
come to her in difficult circumstances
George also mentioned relatively
recently a possibility of a game of
Thrones movie what do you think about
that and what would you like to see
happen on that big screen I'd love to
see Roderick comeback that would be I
think you know given the scale in the
success of the series it I imagine
you're looking at the same kind of thing
that happened with something like Star
Trek aren't you know you go from the
small screen to the big screen with with
relative ease I would have thought
whether they would do you know repeat
stories of what people have seen already
whether they would take a different
aspect of a storyline that hasn't been
you know well developed or extensively
developed because you know there's so
much of the books that yeah it's
mentioned but doesn't get the same depth
that George Gibson in print so yeah
anything like that would be fabulous
said I think it would suit I think it
would suit big scale single productions
very very well what was your reaction
when you saw Joffrey 2i on the screen
just delight it's just I mean as I think
it's one of the things for anybody that
reads the books you know from very early
on you're just sitting there going you
know it would be a very good day when
Joffrey finally gets it so I think
everyone you know the community around
the world when
you know he finally got what was what
was coming to finally would you like to
say to fans the show who are watching
this video oh thanks you know thanks for
thanks for enjoying us thanks for
putting the show up where it is and you
know keep on keep on watching keep on
having good fun
you